.
>> Hannity: PETER, YOU HAVE
DONE A PHENOMENAL JOB ALL WEEK.
THANK YOU FOR EVERYTHING YOU ARE
DOING.
UKRAINIANS ARE BATTLING FOR
THEIR CAPITAL.
THEY ARE PUTTING UP A STRONG
RESISTANCE.
VOLUNTEER FIGHTERS ARE
REPORTEDLY PATROLLING CENTRAL
KYIV, AS RUSSIAN FORCES ARE
CLOSING IN.
ONE MEMBER OF THE UKRAINIAN
PARLIAMENT IS SAYING THAT SHE'S
ARMED, READY TO FIGHT, AS PUTIN
INVADES THE COUNTRY.
SHE JOINS WITH THE COUNTRY.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US,
IT'S VERY BRAVE OF YOU.
WHAT'S THE LATEST WHERE YOU ARE?
>> I AM IN KYIV RIGHT NOW
SITTING ON TOP OF THE STAIRS.
THIS MEANS THAT THERE IS NO
AIR FORCE ATTACK.
IF THERE IS AND THERE'S A SIREN,
THEN I WILL GO WITH MY FAMILY
UNDER THE STAIRS, AND THIS IS
WHERE WE HIDE.
WHEN THERE IS NO AIR FORCE
ATTACK, WE ARE GATHERING
TOGETHER TO GET DEFENSE OR
RESISTANCE GROUPS.
I AM SUPER PROUD OF THE THING
DOMINIC TEAMS THAT ARE
PATROLLING THE CITY.
THEY ARE REMOVING MANY RUSSIAN
SOLDIERS WHO WERE TRYING TO GET
IN.
WORKING ON STRATEGIC OBJECTS,
AND THEN, THE DEFENSE OR
TERRITORIAL DEFENSE GROUPS ARE
HELPING OUT TO CLEAN UP THE
MESS, IF THERE IS A MESS.
>> Hannity: IT'S BRAVE OF YOU
TO STAY.
IT'S BRAVE OF YOUR COUNTRYMEN TO
FIGHT.
IT'S A DAVID AND GOLIATH
SCENARIO: YOU ARE OUTMANNED,
OUTGUNNED.
THE RUSSIAN ARMY HAS PROVEN
ITSELF SO FAR TO BE BRUTAL.
USUALLY, IN CASES LIKE THIS,
WHEN IF, IN FACT, THE CAPITAL
DOES FALL AS MANY ARE PREDICTING
IN THE NEXT 48-72 HOURS -- I
HOPE IT DOES NOT HAVE BEEN THE
KEY OF -- IF IT HAPPENS, YOU
KNOW THAT YOU WILL BE ON THAT
LIST OF TARGETS JUST LIKE
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY, WHO IS THE
AARON KEY HAVE, AND IT'S SAYING
THAT HE'S NOT LEAVING, FIGHTING
TO THE END.
>> IT WAS MY HONEST DECISION TO
STAY HERE AND NOT LEAVE.
ONE POLITICIAN, I REPRESENTING
MY PEOPLE.
THEY DIDN'T GO ANYWHERE.
SECOND, BECAUSE -- I WOKE UP,
LOOKED AT ALL OF THIS, AND WAS
JUST THINKING "WHY WOULD WE DO
THIS?
WHY WOULD WE GO AWAY?"
HE'S COMING THROUGH WITH HIS
FORCES, AND WE ARE ABLE TO FIGHT
HIM BACK, AND ARE DOING IT WELL.
NEWT, LOST LIKE 3,000 MEN, WHICH
IS PROBABLY THE MOST HE LOST IN
THE LATEST WAR THAT HE WAS
FIGHTING THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
THE UKRAINIAN ARMY IS FIGHTING
HIM VERY HARD.
WE ARE RESISTING IN THE BEST
WAYS OF THE RESISTANCE.
I BELIEVE THAT WE WILL BE ABLE
TO FIGHT BACK.
THERE IS INDEED SOMETHING THAT
WOULD HELP OUT.
IF THE NO-FLY ZONE THAT -- WE
HAVE BEEN ASKING FOR IT FOR THE
LAST THREE MONTHS OR SO.
IT STARTED WITH "WE CANNOT HELP
YOU" TO "LET'S SEE WHAT WE COULD
DO."
THIS IS I'M NOT MOVE FROM NATO
AND -- IF IT FAILS, NEXT IS
POLAND, OUR NEXT ARE BALTIC
COUNTRIES.
WHAT'S THE WORLD GOING TO DO
WITH THAT?
THAT'S WHY WE ARE FIGHTING FOR A
BIGGER GENERAL IDEA OVER THE
SECURITY ORGAN.
ED IS GOING TO BE ESTABLISHED.
AS YOU SAID BEFORE, RIGHT NOW,
THERE'S --
>> Hannity: I HAVE TO MOVE ON.
THE WORLD IS NOT SERIOUS IF THEY
ARE NOT GOING TO SANCTION RUSSIA
AND PUTIN ON THE OIL AND GAS.
THAT'S THE LIFEBLOOD THAT HE
NEEDS TO PURSUE HIS TERRITORIAL
AMBITIONS.
I PRAY FOR YOU AND YOUR FAMILY,
FOR YOU AND YOUR COUNTRY.
I'VE HAD CRITICISMS ABOUT SOME
OF THE GOVERNMENT CORRUPTION
OVER THE YEARS.
THIS IS AN INDEPENDENT COUNTRY,
AND THIS IS AN INVASION BY A
THUG AND TYRANT UNDER FALSE
PRETENSES, AND YOU HAVE A RIGHT
TO FIGHT FOR YOUR COUNTRY.
WE WISH YOU GODSPEED, AND I HOPE
THAT THE WORLD WILL HELP YOU, IN
TERMS OF PROVIDING ARMAMENTS SO
YOU CAN TAKE THAT FIGHT, BUILD
THAT FIGHT, BUILD AN INSURGENCY
THAT IS EFFECTIVE AGAINST THE
RUSSIAN ARMY A